hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week you guessed it baby we're on
the last control
unless you start backwards cmmc control
SI dot
l2-3.14.7 that's how I went to Harry
Potter I don't know about you guys when
we read Harry Potter we decided to read
it backwards from the last book to the
first book and it made no sense at all
so you probably actually this is
probably your last control I hope but
stay tuned because we've got a lot more
information there's a lot more than just
the controls you have to comply with so
uh again most importantly let's go
figure out how to solve three fourteen
seven identify unauthorized use of
organizational systems
[Music]
thank you
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 800171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here in on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it baby both feet all the way let's get
it done all right the final control the
last two raw the end of the road the
race to the Finish it's all within sight
I personally love that the last control
is a call out to summarize all the
previous controls the best they could do
it all right in this control we must
demonstrate that we have the ability to
recognize threats to cui and to our
systems they want to know that after
everything else the end result is that
you can recognize uh before something
bad happens that you have a problem and
I think it's a brilliantly ordered uh
thing you know to make this the last
control let's Dive In the assessment
points to discover how they want this
answered answer formatted and answered
for
two things you're looking for okay
determine if authorized use of the
system is defined
implemented via the it use and cyber
security policy firewall policies
endpoint management policies there's a
lot that goes into this but ultimately
if we're following all of our policies
and if our systems are firing off the
way that they should be firing uh we
should be able to have a clear
definition of when uh system uses
authorized versus unauthorized so again
there's a lot of different places that
will look there but that's a good answer
second assessment Point determine if
unauthorized use of the system is
identified so first is to turn if it's
authorized second if it's unauthorized
again here we're going to say Implement
via the it use and cyber security policy
firewall policies and endpoint
management policies along with our seam
solution triggering our ticketing system
when unauthorized use may be detected
okay that's key in that answer because
again all of those alerts combine and
compile and they should raise the red
flags that you need to go investigate
something that it might be on authorized
eyes and that's the way to answer that
control
so hey an on-call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this defars nist itar and CMC compliance
stuff dropped in their laps like a
seagull on a sunny day and we teach you
how to level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliances your secret weapon
to land more Defense work with higher
profit margins now that's what becoming
on-call compliance hero can do for you
and the great news is if you've been
banging your head against the wall for
six months 18 months two years guys
that's normally how long it takes I want
to help you in two to three days okay
most small to mid-sized companies under
a thousand employees we're knocking this
out in two to three days larger
companies yeah it's gonna take a little
bit longer we're still the fastest most
efficient highest quality solution there
is to getting compliance solved for you
and even if you want managing it on an
ongoing basis again this is what we eat
sleep live and breathe if you're looking
for more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmfc complianceecrets.com
check out the bio below for links to get
help right now if you love the content
we're putting out here for you help us
out with a big thumbs up on that like
button or even better smash the
Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance starts roll it out again
while this may be the last control
because we're constantly putting out
videos we're constantly answering
questions uh we're putting out tons and
tons of new content every day and it's
not going to stop now it's only going to
get better all right Better Together
hey until the next compliance hit my
friends stay safe and secure out there
hit us in the comments below to let us
know what you'd like to know more about
when it comes to information security
and compliance and I'll see you on the
next one
[Music]